♪ (SOMBER PIANO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MAN:
Excited about getting out?
Louis, this is Karen James.
-Hi, Ms. James.
-Hi.
I hope you do know
that I very much regret
what I did to your brother.
I was a... very dumb kid
when I did that.
-Used to be the man, right?
-(RAIN POURING)
BEECHER:
I heard you was a mad O.G.
LOUIS:
I did my business with dignity,
self-respect.
That's what you wanna try
to hold on to in here.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
INMATE: When he get out,
after 30 years?
Released 30? Shit!
(LAUGHING)
I've tried to use these years
here to be a better human being.
Have you been thinking
about a job strategy?
You're comfortable
with reading and writing?
Mm-hmm.
You supposed to be bringin'
the whistle in.
-A piece?
-BEECHER: Through the auto body.
-LOUIS: Seriously gon' do this?
-Do what?
Get brothers killed?
That Beecher kid
is gonna get patched.
It's in your best interest
to stay away from him.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
May I say something?
I'm sure that you are
a different person.
But I don't want you to get out.
I can't find my way out
of this shit.
-I need your help.
-(RAUCOUS BICKERING)
I know you know things!
KAREN JAMES:
You should remain in prison
for the rest of your life.
♪ (MUSIC ENDS ABRUPTLY) ♪
LOUIS: There are many days
that I wondered if you're right.
That this is where I belong.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪